Matthew there's nothing in the laws of
physics to prevent nanobots microscopic
robots from circulating in the
bloodstream and bulking us up strengthen
our bones giving us the power of
Superman there's nothing in the laws of
physics to prevent that however the
reality is much much more complicated
let's take a look at nanotechnology
today it's very primitive it is a
multi-billion dollar industry only
because we use it for coatings coatings
to make fabrics stronger and coatings
for different kinds of appliances we
also used it in airbags believe it or
not there's a tiny sensor and
accelerometer in your airbag be
complements of nanotechnology that
create the gigantic explosion of an
airbag but that's today the promise is
that in the coming decades with carbon
nanotubes with graphene will create even
new substances which can replace the
silicon of computers maybe even give us
a space elevator
graphene for example is a substance made
out of one molecule thick layer of
carbon think about that think of like
saran wrap made out of one molecule
thick carbon atoms that graphene is so
strong in principle you can take an
elephant put the elephant on a pencil
suspend the pencil on graphene and
graphene will not break that's how
strong it is it is the strongest
material known to science at the present
time however having these nanobots in
our body that is decades away
we can't even create a nano bot that is
large that'll do most of these things on
a microscopic scale forget going down to
the atomic scale so to summarize yes in
principle there's nothing in the laws of
physics to prevent nanobots from
invigorating us changing our molecular
structure changing our bone structure
and skeleton however the practical
implementation of that is staggering
it's not going to happen for many
decades to come
you